- [Narrator] The creation
of the potato chip
is a rather snarky, surprising,
and idiosyncratic story.
When French fries made
their way to America,
they soon became a restaurant mainstay.
Many restaurants served Fries
as their signature dish.
Believe it or not,
they were once considered
very hoity-toity.
In 1853, George Crum was a
chef at the Moon's Lake House
in Saratoga Springs, New York.
Their signature dish was none other
than Moon's Fried Potatoes, or
as the aristocrats would say:
"Potatoes served in the French Manner."
One day, just like any other,
a customer some believe
to have been Cornelius
Vanderbilt himself ordered fries.
Upon being served, Cornelius
scoffed, and sent them back.
He deemed the fries soggy
and not crispy enough.
This insanity continued a few
more times until Crum lost it.
I mean, he really lost it.
He fired back, cutting
the potatoes paper-thin,
and frying them up.
You see, back in 1853,
eating with your hands
was a major faux pas,
making Crum's revenge
even more diabolical.
By cutting the potatoes paper-thin,
there would be no way that
Cornelius could use his fork,
forcing him to use his hands.
Crum's plan backfired, kind of,
as the patrons dug in with
both hands, and loved them.
Saratoga Chips were born.
They became a Saratoga dining staple.
Soon thereafter, they
took the world by storm.
Crum himself even opened
his own restaurant
with baskets of chips displayed
on each and every table.
(cheery xylophone music)